today's video we actually covered uh one
of his guys videos before
and uh he didn't reply until about a
year and a half later so i decided to
watch the reply
and uh you'd seen it right you've
watched the video i beat it okay so i
watched in this entirety and i would
start this off by saying he makes
a lot of great points in the video that
he did this time around it's worth
listening we're not going to play it's
entirely rolling and play a couple
segments that we want to reply to
but i do recommend you guys go watch it
and it's full and you do so with an open
mind
because like i said he is uh much more
informative in this video than he had
been passed are we
really interested in having a
conversation about hiv
and disclosure or are we only interested
in furthering hiv stigma
if we are really interested in combating
hiv
we also have to be combating hiv stigma
so that means listening to people with
hiv
you cannot see how to combat hiv stigma
because you're too busy looking at hiv
when i say that that means that you
automatically are repealed and disgusted
by it automatically
that you just you that you think that a
person who is living with hiv
should like be locked up i'm going to
start this video by saying i've never
held that sentiment nor
do i hold it today my problem with your
comments
weren't rooted in some kind of despise
of people my sentiment towards that is
quite the opposite
in fact back in my home country i've
known quite a few people who've had it
and so for me it's not something to take
lightly nor it's something i mock
or i wish to make fun of but more than
that it's not something that i wish to
look
at as if you should be quarantined and i
think i said that in the previous video
as well
so i do understand that some people look
at it that way and some people do have
that attitude towards that
but it's not the approach that we took
uh when it comes to this noise of
opinion that i personally hold we seek
for not disclosing
and we see how not helpful that is
people are the folks who are
transmitting hiv the virus
are people who do not know that they are
positive um
i don't know that exactly like one i
think it's one out of four um or one
like what is it i forgot what it is but
so many
folks are walking around um and they do
not know that they are positive
they don't know because they're not
getting tested
he's correct he's absolutely right about
that most furtherance of
any kind of sti or cd is done so because
people are not one take testing
uh and therefore walk and run unaware
and continuously spreading it it's not
malicious people who are out there
trying to spread hiv on purpose that's
like
you know the odd story out it's really
the fact that people are not
knowing that they have something or
people are afraid that they do
and are too afraid to go get tested and
so they'd rather just not go do it and i
understand why it's like
getting tested and potentially finding
out you're positive is super frightening
it's not an easy thing to handle and so
he is correct about the fact that
a lot of people just don't know that
they got something because they don't
want to get tested
that's that's a fact that's a fact and
why are they not getting tested
for a lot of reasons maybe they don't
have the resources where they are
um but a lot of it is hiv stigma no one
wants to
test positive uh but what we should be
focusing on
is everyone is getting tested and no
matter if you are negative
or positive you are getting to care so
that means if you are
negative that means that you're gonna
stay negative that means if you become
positive that means that we'll get you
in treatment we're getting you in the
right stuff we're getting the resources
and the stuff that you need to live a
long healthy life
that's what we should be thinking about
i don't know why people seem to think
that them um posting a video
about hiv disclosure and just railing on
them is content when it's like
this is not content says this is like
this is clickbait stuff
like people use hiv clickbait all the
time like look on youtube
i promise there's a lot of folks who do
that okay two things
one i can agree entirely with your point
in regards to
what we need to encourage and what we
need to do going forward i agree
get people who are tested so that they
can test negative and that we know
and they can stay negative and if you
are positive you get the treatment
without people looking at you
like you're you're you're garbage
whatever i agree 100
and i can still disagree with the
sentiment that you put forth in regards
to the
responsibility aspect part of our
responsibility as a society that we have
not assumed
is that we have not created an
environment where people who are
positive
can feel welcomed that is our
responsibility as society where we have
failed
part of your responsibility as an
individual is that should you be
negative
you continue getting tested so that you
don't spread it and should you be
positive
if you are going to engage in any kind
of intercourse anybody
you disclose it i don't care if you're
fully medicated and your viral account
is like next to zero
and the odds of you transmitting if the
other person is going to care about
whatever you got going on and you know
that they would if they found out
afterwards
tell them beforehand lay your cards on
the table so that both people are going
in
know it now is it true that it should be
the other individual's
responsibility to ask you and to put for
that foot agreed
we agree on that but just because they
don't doesn't mean you don't have that
responsibility
just because they're irresponsible
doesn't mean you don't have that
responsibility
i'm not putting the sole responsibility
of all of it on you i do think it's both
parties but just because one party is
not doing their job
doesn't mean you can also abstain that's
the entirety of my point
um but let's get into the video at hand
in the video i had talked about that
it's not
a person um living with hiv job to
disclose and folks were oh my gosh
that means you're not disclosing but in
the video because the actual video the
live stream that i did is like 10 to 12
minutes long
and i explained in detail why is should
not be
the person who is living with hiv and
disclose
like i don't want to automatically come
into every conversation
and just be the first one bringing it up
i get tired of that
i got tired of it like even if you're
tired that's what it is
that's right i'm really sorry about that
but yeah i can understand the sentiment
that you get tired about talking about
it i can understand that
it can be very tiring and the rolling of
the eyes and you see people can be
disgusted by it because of the stigma
like you say i can understand that
but you still have to disclose it when i
was a kid and you date girls when
you date girls or you go see your
friends whenever you go to your friend's
house and
you have to make sure that the girl
knows do your parents know that i'm
black you should know you're black too
and you're so you understand that it
gets tiring
it gets tiring to talk about all these
issues all the time it is
i want to just walk down the street and
not be tired
of the cop pulling me over for whatever
reason and not be afraid because that
gets tiring but guess what
you do have to deal with that you
understand what i'm saying further
more than sti and hiv or anything like
that
if you are or you have or you are in a
situation
that the other person would like to know
and you do not disclosing you're lying
by omission
if you know that the person would care
about not even talking about that sti or
anything like that or whatever
anything if you know the person with
care that you have kids
disclose that if the person will care
that you have a girl you would care that
you have
disclose that that's what anything i
just don't see in what world
transparency
is a bad thing i can understand it's a
burden and it's difficult
but a bad thing no i think for
everyone's sexual health for everyone's
peace of mind it's going to be an
overwhelming positive we didn't say
nothing about that
that's the thing i was ready to listen
and that's what we said in the previous
previous video points and everything and
i'll listen if someone brings me points
but if we come up with that attitude
miss abba miss preach or whatever the
name is
i actually understand why he said that
to us because when things
are close to you and you feel like
people are pointing the fingers at you
you feel like you're under attack i get
that but that was not the case
we're not trying to attack or anything
like that and it's not the stigma that
we're trying to do we're really trying
to have a conversation
even though even if we do the funds and
games and you see me hollering at me
laughing at me falling back there on the
couch
we still want to have a conversation so
when we laughing we're not necessarily
making fun of you
it's a situation where what was said or
anything like that
that being said no i didn't i wasn't
just
disgusted or anything like that it's
just the points that were made were
non-existent
at the time and i think for everyone
who's at home watching
it's not just about the people living it
with it that have to have this
conversation
even you if you're watching and you have
this like disgusting take about anybody
who has a disease like this
you're part of that problem yeah he's
right about that if you stigmatize
people and you make it such a disgusting
thing
and you're saying this in front of other
people what if your friend thinks he
catches it well he doesn't want to be
seen as that so he's less likely to go
get tested
so you can't have an attitude where you
ostracize people
because of what they're suffering from
because that's not good for everyone as
society
because it puts everyone at risk so
that's also your
response whether you have something you
don't straight whatever whether it's
herpes all this stuff
do not demonize people because they've
caught something like this because it's
a burden
to live with this kind of stuff and when
you do you make it harder for everyone
who is gonna have it who may catch it
because someone's too afraid to
to get tested all this stuff so we also
have to be better
i'm extremely tired of being the one
that to be the first one to have the
conversation
the first one to have the conversation
each and every time
which tells me that it really does not
matter until you are positive which is
kind of not like kind of backwards
because you should be asking that every
time
and then when you look at research we
look at the data
it is people who are assuming they are
negative that are transmitting the virus
it's actually like it's actually less
likely for you to contract
hiv uh with having sex with or engaging
in sexual activity with somebody who is
hiv positive and on medication so while
we are trying to make
like people living with hiv the
boogeyman and the booking folks and out
here
doing all this doing thriller everywhere
in actuality it's the stigma that's
caused
if we don't out we don't like start
combating a stigma we're not going to
like we're not going to do anything
like just posting a video and ragging on
somebody and making it just like a short
clip
that came literally from two
heterosexual men who wanted to have
a conversation us no we're misses
remember
this miss alba miss preach we'll just
talk about this yeah
about something that they feel is
disgusting
no we never we never said that you also
have to acknowledge that you are
projecting
things that you've dealt with onto us
and assume that's our stance i've never
said that
go look anywhere online you will never
find a record of me saying that
nor will you find anything overt like
that because i don't believe it i've
never believed it
so that's why i'm not worried when you
say that so understand that you're
projecting that bias onto us and just
where do you think we're coming and
you're not knowing us you don't know
you saying that it's either you didn't
watch the video because you stormed out
because you you saw it and you're like
and you you rage quit it
or you're really doing what he's saying
and you just all the things that you you
just assumed that we're the same people
that you suffer stigma from that's not
what it is i think that just ain't it
bro
that ain't it front of an audience that
does not have language
not gonna like that i'm not gonna say
ignoring them just like don't have the
language to be able to
have a conversation you sing to us that
we don't have the language
when when you answered to our video
there was no language there from your
part as well
so if you're talking about language and
you want to have a discussion that is
not a problem but we didn't go there i
was
waiting for you to have the language and
enlighten me on some points but you know
what but you know
you came i get it you know when you are
someone who admits to being hiv positive
and you're on these platforms
i imagine you get all kinds of follow
comments sent to you on a regular basis
and then you know us on top of that
might trigger you i get that
you know i'm not going to sit here and
be potentially oblivious to why your
reaction may have been the way that it
was
okay you took some time you came back
you were much more thoughtful
it's a 20 minute video guys if you guys
get the chance go watch it and
and one thing i say when i say go watch
it doesn't mean you go over there and
you flame the person
all our fans or supposed fans who go out
to flame other creators because they
reply
that's trash all right and i'd have
never condoned that if you do that
you're trash to me but anyways moving on
i get that you may have felt that
and i think this conversation is a
difficult one and you feel like maybe
you have to have it all the time so you
get tired so
i'm not even gonna hold you for that i'm
gonna forget the the previous video
and if there's language that i use that
may have gone too far maybe calling you
trash
like that i apologize now as far as this
discussion goes it's super important
that we have it
it's super important that we
destigmatize things like you say
in that regards i think we'd both like
to offer any insight in that regard so
that's why we're making this video and
and and letting people know it's okay to
talk about these things
and if you do think of people less then
because they have
whatever it is or something like that
this is part of the problem you're part
of the issue
right so those are uh
my general thoughts on the topic all
right well um
let's see we're still in the same dusty
old room that he mentioned
this small amount of subscribers ain't
gonna get y'all nowhere anyway y'all
don't
ain't nobody inviting y'all to speak on
nobody's day you will sit in front of
that dirty closet in that dirty room
and talk in front of a an old outdated
camera
and react to videos then it's your
legacy and watch mine grow
yeah yeah yeah same shitty camera same
shitty camera that's your room but we
been one of our point whatever followers
so i have to be a little bit pity again
watch my legacy grow and not you not and
and
people but you know what you know what i
had to be a little bit
again yes
[Laughter]
but i will say this i do wish and i mean
this earnest
i wish you the best going forward i'm
not you know i'm not on this platform
hoping terrible things for people
and i do think that the work that you
want to do is really important if you go
watch
back to video we said that so i hope you
understand we're not trying to denigrate
that so we do wish you the best going
forward and
and and we hope that people do get
better about this kind of topic and
talking about stigma and things like
that so that's my thoughts on the topic
more power to you that's pretty much it
[Music]
foreign